ja und die heutige entscheidung wird
eine schwierige sie könnte im
schlimmsten fall über leben und tod
entscheiden führen die
ministerpräsidenten und die kanzlerin zu
früh lockerungen ein ja da könnten die
fallzahlen und die todeszahlen wieder
steigen kommt die lockerung zu spät dann
wird die wirtschaft länger und stärker
leiden müssen und damit der
gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt also es
wird entschieden ob wie und wann schulen
geschäfte firmen wieder öffnen das
kontaktverbot gelockert werden könnte
für uns beobachtet die gespräche den
ganzen tag über peter tiede am
kanzleramt 9 uhr also in diesen minuten
tritt das corona kabinett zusammen um 14
uhr die video schalte mit dem
ministerpräsidenten das sind die
offiziellen zahlen und zeiten peter was
passiert aber in der zwischenzeit was
wird im hintergrund verhandelt und was
wurde denn schon verhandelt gibt schon
details es gibt schon details also um 9
uhr 30 schaltet sich die kanzlerin
zunächst mit ihrem corona kabinett
zusammen also das sind unter einem der
gesundheitsminister der finanzminister
und der innenminister und da wird das
entschieden was der bund machen kann was
in der verantwortung des bundes liegt
zum beispiel grenzen an andere sachen
masten ankauft dann wird es um 12 uhr
wird sich der regierungssprecher der
presse stellen die
hauptstadtjournalisten haben uns für
immer ihre regelmäßige
regierungspressekonferenz und da wird er
darüber informieren und 14 uhr ist dann
die schalte der bundeskanzlerin mit den
16 ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
zwei ministerpräsidenten kommen dafür
extra nach berlin
einmal markus söder der ist momentan
chef der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher
die drei kanzlerin söder und herr
tschentscher werden dann auch um 16 uhr
etwa je nachdem wie lange man man
braucht vor die presse treten
was sie verkünden werden ist derzeit
noch weitgehend offen denn über ostern
und mit höhepunkt gestern hat sich in
deutschland ziemlich einmaliges
zugetragen die ministerpräsidenten haben
sich fast komplett zerlegt es herrscht
wirklich heftiger streit es ist ein
zweifrontenkrieg die einen wollen
lockerungen die anderen mahnen und
warnen das hat mit den von dir genannten
zahlen zu tun und damit dass wir in
deutschland völlig unterschiedliches
geschehen haben bayern also markus söder
ganz besonders stark betroffen die nähe
zu italien die nähe zu österreich
dort hat man natürlich andere interessen
als es vielleicht bei armin laschet das
wurden die zahlen runter gehen oder wie
sie mecklenburg vorpommern ist es selbst
innerhalb dieser parteien von spd
ländern oder von csu ländern ist man
sich nicht einig dass grünen regierte
baden baden württemberg steht einer
seite bayerns geeinigt hat man sich
zumindest nach unserer kenntnis darauf
dass die reisebeschränkungen also das
reiseverbot und die kontakt
beschränkungen zunächst bis anfang mai
aufrecht erhalten werden dass
grundsätzlich schulen und kitas weiter
geschlossen bleiben auch das bis anfang
mai auch wenn armin laschet gestern
schon der folge noch davon sprach dass
er für einigkeit ist und für eine
gemeinsame regelung gestern für
nordrhein westfalen schon verkündet hat
am montag seine schulen zumindest für
abitur klassen für prüfungs klassen
aufzumachen und kinder vor allem wieder
in die vorschule also in die kitas
lassen zu wollen wird es wahrscheinlich
dann einzelne länderregelungen geben für
die bundesliga wird man wohl
geisterspiele zu lassen und läden bis
400 quadratmeter können in der
verantwortung der länder und kommunen
schrittweise wieder geöffnet werden
damit will man dafür sorgen dass die
deutschen zum beispiel wieder ein
haarschnitt kriegen und dass die
automobilbranche nicht komplett pleite
geht weil wenn keiner mehr es autohaus
kann kauft auch keiner mehr ein auto
wird werden deutschland keine autos
gekauft dann ist unsere industrie den
bach runter peter lass uns das noch ein
bisschen einordnen noch mal ein bisschen
sortieren was da heute alles sozusagen
auf dem tableau steht du hast es
angesprochen es sind schon
ministerpräsidenten vorgeprescht armin
laschet der wahrscheinlich findet alles
bundeseinheitlich regeln aber meine
regeln sollen es sein und auf der
anderen seite markus söder nun sind
schulen ländersache bildung ist
ländersache ist da überhaupt eine
möglichkeit für die kanzlerin besteht
eine möglichkeit hat sie genug macht die
ministerpräsidenten hinter sich zu
vereinen und mit druck der kanzlerin
dort tatsächlich zu einer einheitlichen
lösung zu kommen
also es ist nicht aufgabe der
bundeskanzlerin die 16 bundesländer auf
ihre linie zu bringen oder auf eine
linie zu bringen die die kanzlerin kann
der allenfalls um moderieren die
bundesländer müssen sehen
dass sie im sinne der bürger
nachvollziehbare regelung hinkriegen
dass wir einen fahrplan kriegen und dass
wir bundesweit einheitliche kriterien
nach denen dann entschieden wird wenn
die kriterien einheitlich sind wenn die
kriterien klar sind und nachvollziehbar
sind für jedermann nachvollziehbar sind
dann kann man auch erklären warum in
mecklenburg oder in hamburg und
schleswig-holstein andere regeln gelten
als zum beispiel dann in bayern wo wir
mehr infektionsgeschehen haben und alles
das was heute beschlossen und an
erleichterungen steht unter einem
vorbehalt dass die zahlen zurückgehen
oder sich zumindest stabilisieren wir
haben es gehört vom robert-koch-institut
es ist keine entwarnung da von daher
würde es auch als brandgefährlich und
experten eingeschätzt werden armin
laschet von einer normalität spricht die
wiederhergestellt werden müsste
eine verantwortungsvolle normalität es
kann keine normalität geben wenn die
zahlen nicht wirklich dramatisch
zurückgehen und wenn wir keine
medikamente und impfstoffe haben und
wenn wir keine masken haben und darüber
wird dann gestritten werden und da wird
die kanzlerin ein falls moderieren
können ziel von allen 17 also den 16
ministerpräsidenten und der kanzlerin
muss es sein den deutschen
nachvollziehbare kriterien und ein
einheitliches bild liefern zu können und
ob das ganze dann nachvollziehbar ist
oder nicht wenn man dann später erfahren
peter h vielen dank für deine ersten
einschätzung vom kanzleramt